le crime particulièrement violent choque
toute la région car le vieil homme a été
torturé à mort d'après l'enquête ses
tortionnaires étaient plusieurs mais un
seul homme est arrêté
un délinquant connu de la région
Besançon dans le Doubs
au sud de la ville la zone industrielle
de Chalezeule ou Jean-Pierre Merlot a
été assassiné dans cette entrepôt
Christelle Sagnes a rendez-vous avec
l'ancien associé de son oncle
Jean-Luc bonjour ça va
après trois ans d'enquête l'instruction
vient d'être bouclée le meurtrier
présumé a été renvoyé devant la cour
d'assises
le procès est prévu normalement cet
automne donc on va patienter jusque là
oui oui
vous attendez besoin de faire notre
deuil surtout besoin d'avancer aussi
parce que notre vie elle s'est un petit
peu arrêtée
tout simplement parce que ça reste un
grand flou jusque là on sait pas
exactement ce qui s'est passé savoir qui
et pourquoi tout simplement
cet amertume qui restera et qui restera
permanente
c'était le 21 octobre 2013
Jean-Pierre Merlot un brocanteur de 63
ans est découvert mort dans
l'appartement qu'il avait aménagé sur
son lieu de travail
le crime particulièrement violent choque
toute la région car le vieil homme a été
torturé à mort
l'autopsie du sexagénaire a révélé des
côtes cassées de multiples fractures des
hématomes et des plaies jusqu'à l'os
causées par un instrument de type
tournevis d'après l'enquête ces
tortionnaires étaient plusieurs mais un
seul homme est arrêté
un délinquant connu de la région
alikabouche 27 ans
incarcéré depuis trois ans il crie son
innocence alors que s'est-il réellement
passé retour sur une affaire qui
présente de nombreuses zones d'ombre et
dans laquelle deux familles se battent
pour connaître la vérité
c'est à l'intérieur au fond de
l'entrepôt que l'agression a eu lieu
alors la fenêtre est totalement cassée
là vous voyez il y a ils sont passés par
là on a été obligés de fermer le volet
parce que pour ne pas qui est de
cambrioleur qui entre mais voilà c'était
dans un état des bouts de verre partout
sont passés par là et votre votre oncle
il dormait juste à côté la première vue
oui c'est ce qui dit dans le rapport de
l'enquête il a été surpris pendant son
sommeil
c'est dans le huis clos de la chambre à
coucher que le calvaire du brocanteur
s'est déroulé
l'endroit est resté en l'état depuis le
drame
il y avait en fait des oreillers des
draps il y avait il y avait plein de
choses vu la quantité de sang qui est là
je pense que c'est ici que il s'était
éteint le plus gros c'était la
Christelle n'a pas eu la force de
nettoyer la scène de crime depuis le
passage de la police scientifique j'ai
commencé à faire des sacs parce que
bon il fallait enlever quand même tous
ses habits qui étaient par terre plein
de sang
[Musique]
le brocanteur est mort le lundi 21
octobre 2013 entre 5h et 7h du matin il
a succombé à un arrêt cardiaque après
des heures de ses vis car d'après son
autopsie Jean-Pierre Merlot a subi de
nombreuses fractures et 12 perforations
sur les bras et les jambes à l'aide d'un
tournevis ou d'une perceuse une
agression ultra-violente qui laisse sa
nièce dans le désarroi
pourquoi c'est arrivé là pourquoi autant
de barbarie on va dire dans
qui s'est passé dans la chambre
le crime choque toute la région
car l'oncle de Christelle était très
connu un bon vivant un original
célibataire et sans enfant il se
consacrait totalement à son métier
le brocanteur s'était spécialisé dans le
matériel de restauration d'occasion
qu'il rachetait lors des faillites ou
des fermetures de commerces
[Musique]
son voisin et ami Michel cocard le
connaissait depuis 20 ans
[Musique]
de monter ces enchères 50 100 200
illimité aussi il y avait des gens qui
venaient dans les ventes aux enchères
des habitués et puis des gens pitorer
des façons de parler donc illimité si
ces gens-là leur façon de dire tout ça
donc ça faisait rire les gens quoi quand
quelqu'un venait qu'il connaissait pas
il se mettait comme je dis au garde à
vous de regarder monsieur déclinez votre
identité ça faisait rire ça
grande gueule mais aussi un peu
caractériel l'homme aurait-il eu une
altercation avec un client
les enquêteurs interrogent ces habitués
mais le brocanteur faisait l’unanimité
comme nous confirme Adrien rognon
restaurateur à Besançon
c'est quelqu'un qui qui
[Musique]
ont on se confiait voilà c'était c'était
un monsieur d'une gentillesse qu'on
trouve pas à tous les coins de rue
l'enquête s'oriente rapidement vers un
crime crapuleux car l'appartement a été
méticuleusement fouillée mon oncle
brocanteur communautaire tout brocanteur
a toujours du liquide chez lui bon après
il était pas très discret c'est vrai
tout le monde le savait pas très discret
c'est-à-dire il avait de l'argent dans
sa poche qui dépassait toujours de sa
petite pochette bon bah ça il s'en
cachait pas mais ce ne sont pas que
quelques billets que les agresseurs
seraient venus chercher grâce aux
témoignages de ses proches les gendarmes
apprennent que Jean-Pierre Merlot aurait
caché dans son entrepôt un magot estimé
à environ 50 000 euros voilà pourquoi il
aurait été torturé à mort le but c'était
l'argent rien d'autre ils ont rien volé
d'autres quand on voit tout ce qui est
vélo au milieu ils auraient pu voler
autre chose mais c'était que l'argent
grâce à l'exploitation des bandes de
vidéosurveillance les enquêteurs
découvrent les silhouettes des
agresseurs ils étaient trois mais les
images trop sombres ne permettent pas de
les identifier
l'enquête piétine jusqu'à un
renseignement anonyme reçu par les
gendarmes
incertain Ali Kabouche délinquant connu
de Besançon aurait proposé à Paul un
dealer dans les braquer le brocanteur
réputé pour avoir de l'argent liquide
sur lui
les deux hommes sont arrêtés alikabouche
ni tout implication dans le crime mais
Paul donne une autre version
il va dire que Ali Kabouche voulait
commettre ce forfait qu'il ne voulait
pas le commettre seul et qu'il était à
la recherche de partenaires pour pouvoir
rentrer et pénétrer dans la maison et
rechercher ce butin et il va dire que
dans un premier temps il a refusé
lui-même de s'y prêter et que ensuite
alikabuche dont on dit par ailleurs que
c'est un homme organisé prudent averti
de la grande délinquance va aimer à la
cantonnade tout Besançon pour rechercher
quelqu'un capable de faire le coup avec
lui la version de Paul est retenue
alikabouche aurait donc ensuite recruté
d'autres complices que lui pour agresser
le brocanteur
Paul est mis hors de cause et seul
Kabouche est mis en examen
comme autre élément à charge le juge
retient les expressions que Kabouche
employées pour menacer d'autres
délinquants lorsqu'il était sur écoute
dans les semaines qui ont suivi la mort
de Jean-Pierre Merlot
je vais prendre une perceuse je vais te
percer je mets des coups de cutter
pour Patrick Uzan l'avocat de Ali
Kabouche le dossier est cependant
totalement vide
le résultat des écoutes c'est le fruit
d'une interprétation très
oiseuse
alikabu c'est un enfant de quartier il
parle comme on parle au quartier alors
on va interpréter tous ces mots et tous
ces écarts de comportement et de
conduite d'alicabouche comme
sa capacité à être violent
Emmanuel Pernet et l'avocate de l'un des
neveux de la victime pour elle il n'y a
aucun doute alikabouche a bien le profil
du tueur
il a quand même 12 condamnations à son
casier judiciaire il a un profil de
quelqu'un d'assez violent d'ailleurs
tout son entourage le confirme donc on a
un profil de personnes qui
est extrêmement violent et qui peut
correspondre je dirais à
au crime au crime crapuleux
un passé de délinquant une dénonciation
mais pas de preuve matérielle dans le
dossier car sur la scène de crime aucune
trace de alikabouche n'a été découverte
alors que deux autres ADN masculins non
répertoriés ont été retrouvés donc 1 sur
une trace de sang
[Musique]
c'est pas celui de mon client c'est
celui d'un tiers non identifié mais
après trois ans d'enquête seul
alikabouche vient d'être renvoyé devant
la cour d'assises pour vol avec violence
et acte de torture et barbarie ayant
entraîné la mort
depuis son arrestation l'une de ses
sœurs et sa mère se relève pour aller le
voir en prison et lui apporter du linge
propre
elles n'ont jamais douté de son
innocence
que la vie là elle s'est arrêtée pour
nous on se demande si on est dans un
film ou pas c'est pas la réalité pour
nous c'est pas possible on arrive à
comprendre c'est que dans le dossier il
y a absolument rien du tout on sait que
les personnes qui l'accusent mentent et
c'est prouvé noir sur blanc
mon frère est toujours en prison pour
toute sa famille Ali a été dénoncé à
tort dans les heures précédant la mort
du brocanteur il serait même venu chez
sa sœur monter des meubles de cuisine
aujourd'hui c'est sa mère qui lui rend
visite en prison
le rituel dure maintenant depuis trois
ans
qu'elle sera content il sera content je
suis sûr
mais 20 minutes c'est pas grand chose
à discuter
le caresser un petit peu c'est fini
[Musique]
à Besançon il y a quelques semaines
l'avocat de alikabuche a déposé pour lui
une 19e demande de remise en liberté
avant de plaider il retrouve Rachid l'un
des frères de son client au Palais de
Justice
donc je l'ai vu ce matin comme je vous
l'ai dit il est prudent prudent confiant
et prudent il fallait faire cette
demande pour manifester que on considère
on a strictement plus rien à faire en
maison
on sait pas si ça va être positif et on
lâchera pas la faire
mon frère et puis jusqu'à la fin
la demande de remise en liberté de Ali
Kabouche a été refusé par le juge d'ici
la fin de l'année son procès se tiendra
devant la Cour d'Assise du Doubs
sa famille espère l'acquittement
la nièce de Jean-Pierre Merlot espère
elle connaitre toute la vérité sur la
mort de son oncle et savoir qui était
les complices du principal suspect